how is europe to respond to butcher's
horror
across a continent that's seen so many
atrocities in the past
they're shocked that such killing is
happening again
in western capitals there's almost
complete agreement of what to call them
we're all appalled by the scenes in
butcher
the butchery
the clear evidence of sexual crime of
the targeting of innocent civilians that
it's very clear that war crimes have
taken place
the views of britain's foreign secretary
are echoed in most european capitals we
need to announce a tough new wave of
sanctions
the reality is that money is still
flowing from the west into putin's war
machine and that has to stop
and this is where europe's response gets
thornier and recriminations get bitter
listen to poland's prime minister
macron
mr president macron how many times have
you negotiated with putin what have you
achieved have you stopped any of these
actions that took place
and mr muravitsky attacks germany's
long-standing business and energy ties
with putin's russia
we have to speak out here and now
condemn it admit that it was the wrong
policy because we are dealing with
terrible crimes with the crime of
genocide in the 21st century
germany is still not doing what poland
and the baltic states wanted to
immediately stop buying russian gas we
have to put more pressure on putin and
we have to to isolate russia we have to
to cut all
economic relationship to russia but at
the moment it's not possible
to
to cut the gas supplies we need some
time and so we have to differentiate
between
oil
coal and gas at the moment
while europe mulls more sanctions
germany is declaring 40 russian
diplomats undesirable persons
essentially it's kicking them out france
will expel 35 suspected russian
intelligence officers
but that won't satisfy those who say you
can't justifiably shake one fist in
anger at russia's warmongering whilst
handing over billions of dollars in
energy deals with the other
rory challenge al jazeera